voilà ce qu'il reste des 2000 bottes de
paille partis en fumée dans la nuit
quelques flammes consume les derniers
morceaux dans un champ à l'écart de
baigneux les juifs
il s'agirait d'un nouvel incendie
criminel le sixième de l'été dans le
secteur ce qui a le don d'exaspérer les
agriculteurs c'est un de plus qui sera
le prochain
puis tout seul la question c'est vrai
que cette année on n'a pas eu vraiment
d'un 110 de bâtiments donc ça fait pas
le même effet on écrème aux six ou
septième fois depuis le début de l'été
ça fait quand même beaucoup
on a l'impression que rien qui se passe
pour protéger et nos exploitations et
nos stockages la seule réponse qu'on
nous donne effective aujourd'hui dont on
est sûr c'est qu'on aura plus de
gendarmerie sur le canton dans un mois
en avril 2014 déjà une série de feu
s'était déclenché dans le secteur des
bâtiments agricoles avaient été pris
pour cibles des rondes et des caméras
avaient été installées sans succès et le
ou les auteurs n'avaient pas été
interpellés
face à ce nouvel incendie les gendarmes
vont engager des sommes supplémentaires
pour patrouiller autour de baigneux les
juifs